Just to help us understand how we can do this kind of stuff,
I'm going to simplify this concept and
now showcase a simple way of how we can do a derivative of an image.
Again, you've seen this already just a of the image itself.
Now we're going to look at it with x, which basically means,
in a I'm going to look for a value, x plus 1, which basically means in this one.
And x plus the next column, keep the y the same, and of course, I look for
the original column, x itself.
And I just subtract that and that'll give me the difference.
We have done this in the previous style sub lecture also.
Let's just simplify this and look what we can actually do to
extract basically this concept of derivative as a local product.
Those of you remember from previous lessons, local product, dot product, inner
product was something which was relevant in the concept of cross correlation.
Here, I've just simplified this by basically multiplying the first term with 1
and the second term with minus 1 to get rid of the plus sign here.
Let's rearrange this whole term.
So when rearranged, now we have moved the negative term in front.
And the positive term later.
Of course we can rewrite this form as a dot product.
Of minus and the 1 as a simple vector.
And then, of course, the f x and the f x plus 1,y as the other one.
So this dot product is basically now,
in essence, how we could compute something like this.
Now, of course, this is interesting because, in simple terms,
sometimes I could replace this dot product in case of images with
a cross correlation because in essence that's what this process would be.
So this should start telling us something.
This, for example, could be my kernel and this is my input.
Right?
So looking at that kind of wave we can now start thinking about how we
can actually start doing similar types of processing.
Now of course this is still a dot product.
I'm simplifying this to kind of say this is cross correlation.
We'll look at that in a bit.